travis scott just made his little girl's
dreams of riding on a yellow school bus
come true
and it's the sweetest thing you'll see
all day i can't
while travis and kylie jenner's
three-year-old daughter stormy webster
isn't old enough to take the bus to
school just yet that didn't stop her
famous dad from surprising her with one
she's the cool one on tuesday the kylie
cosmetics founder documented the
adorable moment on her insta story
writing quote all stormy has been
talking about is riding a big yellow bus
daddy surprised her the next pick showed
stormy standing in the aisle of the
empty bus seemingly taking in all its
glory amazing
last week multiple sources confirmed to
et that kylie and travis are expecting
their second child together one source
told et that the couple is quote very
excited to welcome another baby and give
their little girl a sibling adding that
the couple has talked about growing
their family for a while and has always
been on the same page about wanting more
kids meanwhile a second source dished on
how kylie is keeping a low profile
during her second pregnancy telling et
quote kylie loves being pregnant and
enjoyed her last pregnancy out of the
public eye she wanted to be able to have
some of that same experience this time
but it was not the best kept secret
everyone is so happy for her she and
travis are in a great place and this is
something they talked about really
planned for
i love it as for kylie and travis whose
relationship has been on and off for
years ever since they first started
dating in 2017 a third source shed a
little light on their current status
explaining that they're doing great and
kylie really feels like travis has gone
out of his way to re-prove himself to
her the source also added that the
kardashian jenner fam is very supportive
of them being back together and really
enjoys spending time with him plus the
famous fam has taken notice that travis
is striving to be the best father and
partner he can be and they are quote
very impressed
[Music]
you